ANNA PATTERSON: My dad was a
NASA engineer, so he brought
us on a tour at Johnson Space
Center, and they asked my
brother what he wanted to be,
and he said an astronaut.
And then they asked me
what I wanted to be,
and I said an astronaut.
And they said, what?
Girls can't be astronauts.
In their mind, they
were right.
They just didn't realize that
the future would be different.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: It's hard when
you're young, when you're a
teenager, there's a lot of
peer pressure to conform.
ANGELA LAI: There is a certain
astigmatism to being a woman
in technology.
It doesn't seem to be something
that you do.
JEN FITZPATRICK: I didn't want
to be stuck as my desk
programming on a computer eight,
10 hours a day every
day for the rest of my life.
That's just not how
I saw myself.
But so much of it is also
collaborating with other
people and brainstorming
and problem solving.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: It's
working as a team.
It's building things together.
ANGELA LAI: It always
feels like play.
It doesn't feel like work.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I'm always
surprised that there are not
more women going into tech,
because I think it's growing,
and there are just lots
of opportunities.
ANGELA LAI: There is no
roadblocks being a woman in
technology.
PAVNI DIWANJI: There are
a lot of naysayers.
They're like, don't do that,
you're never going to be
successful.
And so one of the things I
learned very quickly is you've
got to stay focused, and you
just have to believe in
yourself and just
make it happen.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: I come into work
everyday excited about
the challenges and the
possibilities.
JEN FITZPATRICK: It's incredibly
satisfying to know
that you're doing something that
has that type of impact
and that type of reach.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: You really
feel like you're doing
something that's helpful and
that's making a difference.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I'm able to
create something that most
universities in the world use.
How impactful is that?
GAYATHRI RAJAN: Five million
businesses use the products
that I've been working on.
ANNA PATTERSON: Every time
you type in a query,
you're using my code.
And that means that
I'm reaching
billions of people a day.
JEN FITZPATRICK: You see the
impact every single day on
real people and your friends
and your family.
And that's just magical.
MEGAN SMITH: Hello, welcome to
Women Techmakers live on
location at Google I/O. It's
incredible to be here.
We have a fabulous lineup
of speakers.
We've set up this session as a
series of lightning talks.
So we want to ignite and inspire
with that topics
around Search, of course, but
also Google Glass, some
product insights, AI, knowledge,
and other topics.
I've asked all of our speakers
to tell personal stories as
they walk through
these topics.
And we have a bit of a theme of
past, present and future.
But before we start--
I don't know if my slide thing
is advancing, so I'm going to
come over here.
No.
Sorry guys.
There.
So this is the lineup.
And before we start, I want to
talk a little bit about why we
started Women Techmakers.
Last night, we had a fabulous
gathering of the women, a
pre-gathering of the women
who are here at I/O.
And we might be in the minority,
but we're fierce.
And it was really fun, a
good social experience.
And we want to build community
amongst women with our male
colleagues.
We also are working
on visibility.
And women are largely invisible
in technology is
part of our feeling.
And so our goal is to
increase visibility.
Our industry is probably 10%
or 20% technical women,
sometimes a little higher.
We want to get to 50%.
We want to match
the population.
Products are just better when
they're built by diverse
teams-- companies are better,
the world is better.
And that's part of our goal.
I wanted to give a shout out
to real progress that's
happening this year.
Sheryl Sandberg, who is a
fabulous colleague, Google
alum now, leading Facebook with
Mark, has really driven
the national and international
conversation up.
We need to be talking
about these things.
I don't know if people are
familiar with the "Maker
Series." Maker.com, AOL and
PBS have launched this.
It's the modern women's rights
movement's history
documentaries and really shining
a light into actual
fabulous stories, the
backstories, on women that you
haven't really heard before.
And you just saw a video clip,
a montage, of something we've
done, which is called "MAKERS
at Google" down here, which
you can get to on
google.com/diversity/women.
We really want people to know
the stories of the women who
build YouTube, the women who
build Android, the women who
build Search.
And so we've launched this
series starting today.
As part of celebrating what's
going on and some momentum, we
have a long way still to go, but
we've come a long way in
really upping the
conversation.
I just want to shout out to some
of the giants we stand on
the shoulders of.
This is Katherine Switzer, first
woman to run the Boston
Marathon officially.
I encourage you to
watch her story.
The race director tried to
rip her numbers off.
It's on makers.com.
And this is Elizabeth Cady
Stanton, and she's delivering
the Declaration of Sentiments in
the mid 1800s at the first
women's rights convention,
back when women weren't
allowed to go to university
and were not allowed to do
many things.
How many people in this room
have ever heard of the
Declaration of Sentiments?
There's one, two.
Looks like for people on
Livestream, we're probably at
about 10%, which brings me to
the point I want to make,
again, about visibility
and invisibility.
We really have a problem
with how visible
technical women are.
And so I want to jump into two
things before we start.
There's symptoms of a problem,
and sometimes
there's roots of a problem.
And I stumbled across this when
I met Gina Davis, the
famous Academy Award-winning
actress.
Gina was watching TV with her
children when they were young,
and as an actress, she could
see that TV was biased.
And she'd say in the industry,
there's not enough women and
girls on children's
television.
And people would say, yeah, of
course, there's plenty, like
Dora, the "Scooby Doo" girls,
lots of people.
But then she thought,
no, there's not.
Let's measure.
You manage what you measure.
So she measured it together
with USC Annenberg.
And the studies were showing--
and they had grad students
counting by hand--
it's actually three to one
across all of children's
television, the corpus of
children's television of men
and boys versus girls.
And so the girls aren't equally
represented, and you
see amazing things that you
wouldn't even notice.
But how many women in the
whole ocean in the film
"Nemo?" How many Muppets were
in "Sesame Street" who were
girls into the '90s?
That will be zero.
"Nemo?" One.
So we're not accurately
depicting the world, and we're
skewing it.
So one of things we've been
looking to do-- and also, one
more stat, the 80% stat.
80% of the jobs that were held
by characters in the
television our children watched
were held by male
characters.
So we taught our kids that
girls and women don't do
stuff, which just doesn't happen
to be true, as we'll
show in this session.
And so we really need
to get in here.
We are now working with Gina on
trying to automate some of
this, so that we can have a
gender disparity measurement
ability to look at our media.
And I encourage everybody who
has technical background, look
at ways we can use technology
to count bias so we can
measure and see things.
The last thing I'll point out
before we start about things--
oh, one more example.
This is so insidious, like our
bias, that I was looking in a
catalog recently, and this was
a dresser for a boy and a
dresser for a girl.
And the colors are different.
But really, the big difference
to me that I saw because of
being aware of Gina's work
was that the boy got the
microscope and the
girl didn't.
So as you now know this fact,
you're going to notice it
everywhere.
And it's something we
need to work on.
And if we could use technology
to help ourselves see it, we
could get out of this historic
bias that we inherited.
The last thing I would say
before we start is around
becoming visible, includes not
only seeing the technical
women who are here today, but
also the historic women.
How many people recognize some
of the people on these slides?
I see a couple hands, but really
probably these people
are pretty unknown to you.
Ada Lovelace is represented
in the Doodle.
She's from the 1800s.
She's actually the first person
in world history to
think of programming
something.
She's the founder
of our industry.
There's the women who were
Astronaut Corps.
Nobody knew about them.
We know about the men.
Some of the most decorated
Americans, of course, are the
astronauts from the Apollo
and Mercury times.
They were there.
They just weren't
allowed to fly.
Grace Hopper--
this is the Woman
Project at MIT.
The Bletchley code crackers, the
enigma code crackers from
World War II, more than half
women, mathematicians.
Hedy Lamarr.
Hedy Lamarr helps you have
your cell phone work.
Up on the top, there's a
wonderful thing that
Singularity University launched
last weekend.
I encourage all of us to help.
It's a crowdsourced
history idea--
and so innovatingwomen.org.
Please go there, please help
capture these stores.
And last, I want to
point to this
picture down in the bottom--
University of Pennsylvania,
World War II.
I want to bring Kathy
Kleiman on stage.
She's going to share an
extraordinary story from
history that I was lucky Brad
Feldman alerted me to.
He's here.
Kathy.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY KLEIMAN: Thank
you so much, Megan.
I'm thrilled to be here
with all of you today.
And I have an amazing story
to share with you.
But first, I have
two questions.
The first one is, does anybody
here know who invented the
first sort routine?
It was Betty Holberton.
Another question--
who invented the first
software application?
That was Betty Holberton, too.
We don't know about her, because
she was never written
into formal computer history.
In fact, her story was almost
completely untold
for a very long time.
I know, because I found it.
Can we go to the
slide, please?
Thank you.
I know because I found it.
When I was an undergraduate and
a computer programmer, I
felt very isolated.
I didn't see women around me.
I didn't see them
in my classes.
as faculty in my
computer science classes.
So I turned to history to see
if I could find role models.
And I found this picture.
This is of the ENIAC,
the first all
electronic digital computer.
It was a secret project during
World War II at the University
of Pennsylvania.
And when I found the pictures,
the men were in the captions.
That's J. Presper Eckert and
John Mauchly on the left and
right front.
And they're the co-inventors
of the ENIAC-- very famous.
But there are women
in these pictures.
And I wanted to know who
they were, and they
weren't in the captions.
So I took the picture,
and I went to a
leading computer historian.
And I asked her who they were.
And she said the refrigerator
ladies.
I said, a refrigerator lady?
She said they're models posed
in front of this machine to
make it look good, like the
Frigidaire models used to open
the new refrigerators with
such a flourish.
Well, they didn't look
like models to me.
These women look like they
belong in this picture.
And they look like they know
exactly what they're doing.
So I set out to find
them, and I did.
That's Jean Bartik in the
far back and Ruth
Lichterman-Teitelbaum
in the front.
They were two of the original
ENIAC programmers.
And I was thrilled to learn that
all six of the original
programmers were women.
So now I'm going to
take a pause.
Thanks to the wonderful Women
Techmakers, I've been able to
bring you a short video of the
ENIAC programmers telling you
a bit of their story
themselves.
It's part of oral
histories I've
collected over many years.
And I'm thrilled to be able
to share this with you.
[APPLAUSE]
BETTY SNYDER HOLBERTON: From
the very beginning, you're
going to a first in
a lot of things.
JEAN JENNINGS BARTIK: I've never
since, never been in as
exciting an environment.
We knew we were pushing
back frontiers.
NARRATOR: In February of 1946,
six months after World War II
had ended, America learned
of a secret army
project called ENIAC.
It was the first
all-electronic digital computer.
Yet the tale of ENIAC's
programming by a group of
young women has been all but
erased from computer history.
During World War II, the US had
assembled a crew of nearly
100 mathematically trained
women whose
official title was computer--
women who were computing complex
ballistic trajectory
equations by hand and using
mechanical desktop
calculators.
In the spring of 1945, six were
selected to figure out
how to program the
ENIAC machine--
Fran Bilas, Betty Jean Jennings,
Ruth Lichterman,
Kathleen McNulty, Betty Synder,
Marlyn Wescoff.
MARLYN WESCOFF MELTZER: We
were competing ballistic
tables on a hand calculator.
We were computing, and
we were computers.
JEAN JENNINGS BARTIK: There were
logical diagrams on the
ENIAC, and we were supposed to
study them to figure out how
to program it.
The ENIAC was a son of
a bitch to program.
[LAUGHTER]
NARRATOR: ENAC [INAUDIBLE]
Eckert and Mauchly
became famous.
However, the ENIAC programmer
story, the story of these six
women founders who created the
first sort routine, the first
software application, and became
the first teachers of
modern programming,
was never told.
Their work dramatically altered
computing in the 1940s
and 1950s as they paved
the path to
modern computer science.
JEAN JENNINGS BARTIK: At that
time, the emphasis was on the
invention of the ENIAC,
developing and the mechanics,
the hardware.
KATHLEEN MCNULTY MAUCHLY
ANTONELLI: We were like
fighter pilots.
Here was this great, great
machine, but you couldn't just
take an ordinary pilot and
stick them into a fighter
pilot and say, go
to it now, man.
That was not the way
it was going to be.
BETTY SNYDER HOLBERTON: I
had a fantastic life.
Everything that I did was the
beginning of something new.
KATHLEEN MCNULTY MAUCHLY
ANTONELLI: I really loved
working with those girls.
KATHY KLEIMAN: Aren't
they amazing?
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY KLEIMAN: And their work
didn't stop with ENIAC.
They became the first teachers
of modern programming.
They became the first modern
professional programmers.
And Betty and Jean went on to
program BINAC and UNIVAC, the
first commercial computers.
And they created innovative
tools that changed the face of
programming forever.
Absolutely amazing.
And in a very nice twist,
Betty Holberton actually
interviewed Grace Hopper to
invite her down to Eckert
Mauchly Computer Corporation,
the first commercial modern
computing company.
And Grace, of course,
accepted.
Thank you.
So now, today, I have an amazing
announcement to make.
After so many years of
recording their oral
histories, researching their
accomplishments, and working
so closely with the ENIAC
programmers, I'm thrilled to
tell you and I'm thrilled to
announce here that final
funding has finally been put
together so that I can produce
a documentary and finish my book
on the ENIAC programmers
and share the story
with all of you.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY KLEIMAN: This is happening
because Megan Smith
introduced me to two remarkable
technical women of vision--
Anne Wojcicki and Lucy
Southworth Page.
And they're providing wonderful
support through
their foundations, the
Brin-Wojcicki Foundation and a
donor-advised fund on behalf
of Lucy Southworth Page.
And I really want to applaud
them, because this is amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY KLEIMAN: And thanks to
this support, I will be in
production this summer with the
Paul Freeman Film Group,
and we will be producing a
documentary, and we'll have a
book for you very,
very shortly.
I can't wait to share this
story in its full form.
And now I want to share just a
personal story about how I
learned firsthand what history
and visibility can do to shape
our viewpoints.
Ten years ago, when my son was
five, he came over to me with
a very confused look
on his face.
He had grown up with my work on
the ENIAC programmers, and
he had even met and actually
played with four of the
original six ENIAC
programmers.
And he looked upset.
And he said, mom, I know that
women can be computer
programmers.
But can men be programmers
too?
[LAUGHTER]
KATHY KLEIMAN: I assured him
that, of course, women and men
could be programmers.
And in fact, technology
was better when
we created it together.
And when I left him two nights
ago, he was programming.
And so what I want to do and
conclude is say stay tuned for
more about the ENIAC
programmers.
And please join me in the quest
to capture wonderful
stories of women in technology
so we don't lose any more.
And on behalf of all of us,
I want to thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MEGAN SMITH: So now we're
going to start into the
lightning talks.
And I have the honor of
introducing Susan Wojcicki.
Susan has been at Google
since the start.
She's actually our
first landlord.
And I hope she's going to tell
you a little bit about that.
But Susan is our senior vice
president of advertising.
And she really runs all the
products that make all of the
money that allow us to do all
the amazing things that we're
able to do.
She's an extraordinary executive
and extraordinary
visionary strategic leader.
One of my favorites is
the personal stories.
My favorite experiences are--
Susan is always double
and triple-booked.
And she adds a lot of value,
so we get her everywhere.
And often, if you're in a
meeting and there's a lot of
people debating ideas and ideas
are flying around, but
you can't really get moving,
when Susan walks in the room,
it just changes.
Within five minutes, people are
focused on a screen and
narrowing in on where
we're going to go.
She just knows how to lead.
She knows how to see the
future, and she's an
extraordinary leader of Google
and of our industry.
And I welcome Susan Wojcicki
to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
SUSAN WOJCICKI: Good
evening, everyone.
It's really great to see such
a wonderful turnout
for our talk here.
And since this is a developer
conference, I thought I would
talk about a few key principles
that we use when
we're developing Google's
products.
And I've been involved
for a long
time in a lot of products.
So I summarized this
down to two.
But before I do that, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about my personal story.
And since Megan talked about me
being a landlord, I thought
I would start there.
And so when people ask me the
question, well, how did you
decide to join Google, I
sometimes have to say, well,
my story is kind of unusual.
It's not really like everybody
else's story.
I actually lived with
the company
Google for five months.
I don't think really anyone else
can say that, expect for
my husband.
And so what happened was I was
renting rooms in my house, and
Sergey and Larry
had just gotten
funded for their company.
And they were looking
for space, and I
was looking for renters.
We agreed on an amount,
and they moved in.
And at first, I didn't really
think that much about it,
other than they were renters.
But then people would read about
it, and then they would
ask me questions.
And I would say, oh,
yeah, I know them.
They're actually renting
in my garage.
[LAUGHTER]
SUSAN WOJCICKI: So I started
using the products.
And you have to remember,
there were a lot of big
competitors out there that were
much, much bigger than
this little company of three
people at the time.
So I start using the product.
And it was pretty good.
And I had this realization at
one moment, because the site
actually went down.
The servers were still
running at Stanford.
And it was at that moment that
I couldn't reach Google.
And that's when I really
realized how important it had
become to me and my life.
And I realized the potential
for the world.
And that's when I decided I
really wanted to join Google
and be part of that future.
So that's my story on terms
of why I joined Google.
So I joined, and I was
there for one day.
And Sergey comes up to me and
says, I have a mission for us.
It's to organize the world's
information to make it
universally accessible
and useful.
What do you think?
I was employee 16.
There are less than
20 of us here.
And you guys all just graduated
from college.
So that's like a pretty
ambitious goal right there.
But that brings me to my first
point, which is that do
something important, think big,
and have a big goal of
how you can change the world.
And I was really pleased to see
that Larry talked about
that this morning in his
keynote, where he said that
there's so many things that
haven't been done yet.
It's important to focus on the
great things that haven't
happened yet.
And that's really a focus
that we have in
our development process.
And a lot of times, doing
big ambitious things
sounds really hard.
In fact, they sound crazy, and
they sound impossible.
But when you break them down
into parts, a lot of times you
can realize they're
actually doable.
And doing really hard, crazy
things also has the advantage
that it's a lot less
competitive, because there are
fewer people who want to do
crazy things, like you.
So let me give a few stories.
So let me start with
Street View.
So we have the beautiful imagery
that comes from the
Bright Angel Trail in the Grand
Canyon that we have been
working on.
In fact, here in the lobby,
you can actually see the
camera that created it, and you
can actually try on the
backpack and walk around
and see how we did it.
But when I first heard about
Street View, it was just the
idea, which is let's create a
way to take pictures of all
the streets in the whole world.
[LAUGHTER]
SUSAN WOJCICKI: Right?
I'm like, OK.
And then you think about
it, and these ideas
sound crazy at first.
But then you start thinking,
well, how would you do that?
And you start thinking, well,
you would have cars, and they
would have cameras.
You could have people, and
they could have cameras.
And then you start talking,
what kind of cameras?
And then you find people
who actually
really want to do that.
And then you're on your way
to making it happen.
So we just launched our 50th
country with Street View and 5
million miles of Street
View imagery.
So from a very simple idea, we
have something that enables
people to see imagery
from all over the
world, which is amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
SUSAN WOJCICKI: So going on to
the next big idea, which we
are still working on, which
are driverless cars.
Now, if you think about
driverless cars and you hear
about this idea, it also sounds
like this giant idea.
Is it really going
to get done?
Are we actually going to
be able to do this?
And if so, when?
And so there are many, many
benefits, like it's probably
the most dangerous thing we all
do, but yet we have to do
it, which is drive.
And you think about
the benefits of
saving lives and emissions.
And it really could make a
difference in the world.
So my goal is to have the
people at Google do this
before my kids start driving.
So I have a personal OKR here.
But it's just an example of a
really big idea that doesn't
sound possible that you
can make have happen.
So let me move on to the second
big principle that we
think about.
Now, when I'm working with
teams, and they are telling me
they're going to create some new
product or they have some
idea and they want to staff it
and they want to build it, I
ask them, what is
your insight?
Tell me something why you're
doing something new, why
you've observed something in
the world that's different.
And what's your insight that's
going to make this product be
a big success?
And I found that if they can
answer that, the product is
usually a success.
And if they can't, then it's
often time to go back to the
drawing board.
And I think about the insights
as, because there's so much
technology and the world that
we live in is changing so
much, if we go around and we
look really, really carefully
at how the world's changing,
and we see new technology,
sometimes we can see glimpses
of how the world will change
in the future.
And if we can see that glimpse,
then we can build
around it, and we
can plan for it.
And we can build those next
generation solutions.
We can build that future.
So I'm going to give a few
examples, actually, of
insights that have been really
important to me and my product
development and that
have guided me.
And again, a lot of times these
are just one sentence.
But they're powerful, because
it's a nugget that you can use
to build your products.
So I was working on
Google Video.
And as you can see, we have
the YouTube logo here.
And when I was working on Google
Video, we were working
with studios who had
great content.
And we were working to
bring this online.
But at the same time, after we
had just gotten it online and
users were starting to be able
to see it, we had this other
video that became very,
very popular.
In fact, the numbers were
significantly larger than what
we were seeing from
this studio in the
studio deal we had done.
And it made me realize
the power of
user-generated content.
So do you guys want
to see that video?
Yes?
Let me show you a few, just
like 15 seconds of it.
But it was this video that
really gave me that insight
and that inspiration.
[YOUTUBE CLIP]
[APPLAUSE]
SUSAN WOJCICKI: What I love
about that video is that the
roommate is doing his homework
in the background the entire
time and doesn't notice.
But this was an insight.
I realized, wow, this
user-generated content, it can
be really, really powerful.
And today, we all know that,
because that's what the world
has become-- user-generated
content.
It has its place it's
very valuable.
There's also all kinds of other
content that's produced
professionally that's really,
really important to the
ecosystem, too.
But it was that video that
really gave me the confidence
in thinking that we should
acquire YouTube.
And I was a big advocate
of it.
And Google spent
$1.65 billion.
So sometimes you have one little
insight, and from that
little insight, you make
a really big decision.
So I want to talk about another
insight that's near
and dear to my heart,
which is ads.
I'm responsible for Google's
ads business.
Now , we created an ad system
when Google had not very many
people at the company--
I would say probably like 30
people at the company.
And we didn't really have enough
people even to build a
search engine, let alone to
try to build and ad system
where nobody knew anything
about advertising--
nothing.
None of us had ever
worked in it.
But we had an insight.
And that insight is something
that I still use today when I
think about the ad products
that we build.
And the insight is very basic.
But it's ads are information.
Now, if you think about ads
being information and you
think about them just being
commercial information, then
the ads need to be relevant, and
the ads need to be useful.
The ads need to be shown to the
right person at the right
time, just like we think about
that for our search results.
And so that meant we had to
build our own ad system.
That meant that if you typed in
flowers, you had to see ads
about flowers.
That if you typed in the name
of any book, you had to see
all the ads had to be
about the book.
Not just for a bookstore, but
for that actual book.
And so that's a principle that
we use that caused us to build
an ad system.
And if I think about
things today,
sometimes I'll get questions.
Like when we first went into
display, people would ask me,
how do you feel about
image ads?
How do you feel about
video ads?
Do you think an image ad
could not be a good ad?
You think about that.
Well, an image is information.
Are images useful to you?
Yes.
Then an image ad can be useful,
provided its served at
the right ad at the right
time to the right user.
All of it, at the end of the
day, is about serving the
right ad and making it useful.
So that's an insight that
we've used across our ad
business from beginning
till present.
And just going forward, moving
really quickly to the present,
if you look at today,
and you say, what do
you see about today?
What are things that
you're focused on?
I would say we have
to be thinking a
lot more about location.
We have all these phones.
The phones know where we are.
How do we make all the
services that we have
super-relevant to us?
So you think about, all of you
having traveled, probably come
from all different places and
staying in hotels and looking
for places to eat.
How many of you have actually
gotten some kind of offer
related to where you are
right now that would
be useful to you?
I'm looking, but I
see a few people.
They're the brave souls who--
or the people who have
special technology or
have special insights.
But it's something that doesn't
really happen yet.
But there's no reason it
shouldn't and couldn't.
We should all be getting useful
information based on
where we are right now.
And the reason we haven't is
just because the systems
haven't been built out yet.
And so it's just an example of
an insight and the way we
should think about things
in the future.
So just to sum up, those
are my two insights.
That's how we think
about building.
We think about doing things
that are really important,
things that haven't been done
yet, things that will be used
by billions of people.
And to think about insights and
what the future will look
like, get an insight into that
future, and then build for
that future.
And by building for it, that
will become the future.
So I'm very excited about the
future of technology and how
it's changing our world.
I think there are so many
opportunities for us and for
all of you.
And I'm looking forward
to that future.
And now I'd like to invite
Anna Patterson
to come up on stage.
Anna Patterson has worked on
some of the biggest, most
ambitious projects I've
seen at Google.
And she's going to tell you
a little bit about them.
Anna is vice president of
engineering and artificial
intelligence.
What an amazing role
and opportunity.
So let's please welcome
Anna onto the stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA PATTERSON: So I'm here to
tell a little bit of hacker
stories from the trench and I
think with a main theme of
perseverance.
I saw that the ENIAC
programmers, how they got a
circuit diagram in
order to program.
My first programming job out
of school was for the F15E.
And we would test our software
the best you can on something
that wasn't flying.
And then we'd invariably
need to put in patches.
And just like the ENIAC, you had
to toggle in the program.
So it was very scary, since
people's lives were
depending on it.
But also, I was thinking
about how
source control has evolved.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA PATTERSON: Of course, my
first programs in high score
were on punch cards.
But at home, I was really
fortunate that my dad brought
home a Commodore pet computer.
And he encouraged us to
experiment and write
a program on it.
And I wrote a really, really
horrible, terrible video game.
And it only had 8K of memory, so
I stored the program state
in the corners.
So they were flashing weirdly.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA PATTERSON: And I guess
it was a standard trick.
I found out much later.
But I was from the suburbs of
Saint Louis, so I wasn't
really part of a burgeoning
hacker community.
I eventually got my PhD in
computer science at the
University of Illinois,
Champaign.
And then I became a research
faculty member for John
McCarthy, the founder of AI.
And I see several people here
who know me really well.
And so you'll appreciate when I
say that John McCarthy made
me do something, how hard
that must have been.
So he made me look into this
area called phenomenal data
mining, where you're given
facts and relations, and
you're given a big data set.
Big was very small
in those days.
And then when you learn new
correlations, you can explain
these new correlations in terms
of underlying phenomena.
So that's where it
got its name.
And that technique
is still in use.
But everybody was leaving the
department to start companies.
So we were pretty much like
the last ones out when the
lights were turning off.
And I co-founded in 1998
a web mining company.
Because the web was so big at
5 million pages, we thought,
how are people going to be able
to get around this thing?
And so we had an idea to make an
automatic taxonomy and kind
of lead people to what questions
were answerable on
the web and what ones weren't.
Because in those days, trust
me, there weren't really
recipes on the web.
But the taxonomy around
Linux was deep.
So we got angel-funded to
do this just in time
for the dot com crash.
And so I tried to figure out
what my other passion was, and
I said mobile is just
about to take off.
So I moved into the mobile area
in 1999, just in time for
the Telco crash.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA PATTERSON: So after killing
two industries, I had
a one-year-old, and I was
four months pregnant.
And of course, I was unemployed,
and I was actually
living in [? Pogne's ?]
guest room, who is
in the front row.
And so the doctor said, you
need to be on bed rest.
And I said, have you ever
heard of programming?
And he hadn't.
And I said it's a lot
like bed rest.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA PATTERSON: So
I volunteered at
the internet archive.
And they have snapshots
of the web over time.
So as such, especially
in 2001, it was much
bigger than the web.
It had 30 billion web pages.
And the live web at the time
maybe had five billion.
So I did a history-based search
engine that launched
at, like, 12 billion pages.
And you could look at how
terms change over time.
So you could dial back to 1997
and searched for a term like
Clinton, and you'd see all these
co-occuring terms in a
graph and how they changed
over time.
And it was very presidential.
Dialing it up to 1999, it wasn't
quite as presidential.
And then moving forward to
today, everything is about
Hillary Clinton if you search
for Clinton, when you look at
the popularity of the
things on the web.
So it was a really interesting
project.
And I was doing it
as a volunteer.
And four days after it launched,
various companies
wanted to talk about
acquiring it.
So I go from volunteer
stay-at-home mom to the world
of corp dev.
So that was really fun.
So that's how I wound
up at Google.
And at Google, I really wanted
to unlock some global and
local information.
One of our examples was about
these small towns in Germany
with their local Octoberfests
and how that information was
really important to them.
And we weren't quite
big enough to get
everything to everyone.
And so at Google, we
evolve our systems.
So just when one system
launches, we
would start a new one.
So when one such system just
launched, I came up with the
idea for TeraGoogle.
And speaking of thinking big,
probably 95% of people said,
why would we ever need
a search system
for a trillion pages?
And of course, the founders
were like, is that all?
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA PATTERSON: So at the
time, it was very
cost-efficient.
When it launched, it was about
50 times cheaper than our
mainline index.
And at the same time, some of my
web ranking team went off,
and they shipped one of our
early deep learning projects,
which was around
ads broadening.
Like once you bid on one
keyword, what other keywords
might be interesting?
So after having my fourth child,
I did what everybody
does when they have four
kids and they're
on maternity leave.
I decided to start a company.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA PATTERSON: So I started
a company, Cuil.
And we really want to bring
a really high res, rich
experience to people with high
bandwidth and a really low
bandwidth experience to people
who had feature phones.
And so what we did around the
low bandwidth experience is we
summarized things so that a fact
that appeared on tons of
web pages was on top in
paragraph format with a bunch
of references, down to much
rarer facts that had much
fewer references.
So after Cuil, I returned to
Google, where I became one of
the first 100 engineers at
Android, because this time, I
was pretty sure the
mobile revolution
was going to happen.
But it wasn't a sure thing.
At that time, Android had
sold 40 million phones.
And of course, today it was
announced that Android now has
900 million.
I was part of the team that
helped launch Google Play on
Play tablets.
And very recently, like two
weeks ago, we shipped a native
search architecture onto the
phone to index all the local
data, so that when you're
offline, you can
have access to it.
And some data never
leaves your phone.
So a lot of people say, wait,
Google is so good at search.
Why didn't you just compile
the thing and
put it on the phone?
Well, the phone is kind
of like my early
Commodore pet computer--
not quite as bad, but compared
to a data center, it is.
And each of the programs can
only have 20 meg resident in
memory, and the executable is
500 meg as hard constraints.
So trust me when I say that
Google's search system, it's
executable, it's bigger
than 500 meg.
So when we look at this system,
because the success of
Android as a compute cluster,
it's actually over 500
exahertz of computing power,
which is way more powerful
than the human brain.
So last autumn, I moved over
to our new AI area, where
recently, Ray [INAUDIBLE]
joined us.
And he says that the AIs that
humans create are going to
leave the earth at light speed
and populate the universe.
So we're not just working on the
most important project on
planet Earth, but
in the universe.
So I do want to encourage the
tech makers out there, women
and men, to really reach for the
stars and use technology
to help shape the world.
Technology is a very powerful
platform in order to help
people and enable change.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA PATTERSON: Now, I want to
introduce Johanna Wright.
She's the lead product manager
of Search for many years,
launching such innovations as
Universal Search, Instant, and
the Knowledge Graph.
And now she's leading up Search
at Android, including
Google Now Voice Search
and Speech.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Let's step
back to January, 2003.
At this point in time,
I'm living in my
father-in-law's house.
He's put a nice curtain up for
my section of the living room
where my husband and I share
an air mattress.
The sun streams in, 6:00 AM,
we wake up every morning
because of the unbearable
Orange County heat.
The air mattress has popped,
and I'm unemployed.
Just six months earlier, I was a
young tech exec in New York,
first, during the dot com
boom and then bust.
But my company that I worked at
had finally shut its doors.
And my husband and I decided
to get on our bicycles and
ride across the country
to lovely sunny LA.
Riding across the country
with your new
husband is a lot of fun.
Showing up in LA, a new city,
with no job, not so much fun.
Then the rejection letters from
business schools started
pouring in.
And it's January, and there's
only one business school I
haven't heard back from.
But I'm not feeling too
optimistic, because they're
supposed to interview all of
their candidates, and they're
going to mail out their verdict
two days later.
And they still haven't
interviewed me.
But then I got an email from
UCLA, It said we want to
interview you.
And since my confidence
had been shot, my
response was, you do?
I was fortunate enough
to get to go to UCLA
for business school.
And then I got a
job at Google.
And today, I'm going to talk
about my career starting now
to Google and what it was like
to be a product manager at
Google and give some bits
of advice about product
management.
But my first piece of career
advice is that your career is
not going to be linear.
Expect to be disrupted.
This is a disruptive industry.
And you, too, may someday
be unemployed on your
father-n-law's couch.
What's really going to matter is
the energy and the tenacity
with which you pick yourself
up and take
on your next adventure.
So let's jump into Google.
I was hired to be a product
manager working in Search.
My boss gave me two
options of jobs.
One was something called
Universal Search.
Universal Search was the project
where we took all the
content from our different
backends--
Maps, Videos, Images--
and we put them in the main
search results pane.
The other option she gave me
was to do something called
Premium Content Search.
This is where we searched all
the content behind pay walls
and put it in the
search results.
Both of these things seemed
pretty interesting.
And I was so new to Google I
didn't have any context or
judgment to make a decision.
Fortunately for me, I'd gone to
the same business school as
Susan Wojcicki, my
fellow panelist.
And so I asked her
for some advice.
Susan looked at me like
I had two heads.
What?
Of course you should do
Universal Search.
That's our business, Johanna.
So this leads to another
piece of career wisdom.
What does a good opportunity
look like?
A good opportunity looks like
something that's strategic.
If you're doing something
that's in line with a
company's mission and has not
been done before, then it's
very likely to be a
good opportunity.
So let me jump into
Universal Search.
This was 2005 at Google.
Google was growing like crazy.
It was very chaotic.
And for me, it was hard to
know how projects got
assigned, what you
were working on.
And I got paired up with an
infrastructure team while I
was working on Universal
Search.
This was a great team, but a
team that was very focused on
building infrastructure,
and they didn't want
to build any features.
And I was a product manager, and
I was being judged on the
features that I launched.
And so it was pretty stressful,
because I wasn't
delivering anything.
And so what I ended up doing was
creating a set of mocks, a
series of mocks of
what Universal
Search could look like.
And then I created a little
PowerPoint deck, and I walked
around Google, and I introduced
myself to anyone
who looked like they might want
to be a features tech
lead to see if they wanted
to join my project.
And I was fortunate enough to
meet a person named David
Bailey, who wanted to join on
and lead the features side of
the effort.
And then the project really
started to get legs.
So here's the beginning
of my product
management specific advice.
And that is to paint a vision.
Once you paint a vision and you
share your vision, people
will follow.
It'll be a lot easier to follow
once you have a vision.
OK, so David and I started.
There was a big mountain
in front of us.
We didn't really know
what to do.
This project had failed a
number of times before.
We didn't really know
why it had failed.
And I had this idea that we
should do a user study.
I was trying to figure out what
to do, so I said, let's
just do a user study.
So we pulled together
a prototype
to do our user study.
And once we had this prototype,
the people around
us at Google started to be
able to imagine that this
product might come to life and
that something might happen.
And so this brings me to my
second piece of product
management advice, which is that
if you don't really know
what to do, you should
just do something.
Do something to move
the ball forward.
I was very fortunate, though,
that a user study was what we
decided to do, because
people loved it.
And it was so awesome.
We learned that the project
and the product had legs.
So I remember sitting in the
labs, and it was in the spring
of 2006, for our user study.
And one of the searches we ask
people to do was Barry Bonds.
This was a long time ago.
This was the Dark Ages.
YouTube was just starting out.
But there was a home video that
someone had uploaded of
Barry Bonds tying Babe Ruth's
home run record.
And the participant
in our study, she
clicked on the video.
She watched the ball sail
out into the field.
And there was this big
smile on her face.
It wasn't unnatural at all that
she saw this video in the
search results.
So we knew the project
had legs.
And it was just a
great moment.
So my final and most important
piece of product management
advice is to listen
to your users.
And even more importantly, use
your products yourself.
Just this weekend, when I was
using Android Search, I
noticed that speech recognition
is slow, like
maybe one in seven times.
I don't know why.
But I'm really glad that we're
investing in speed.
And then I also had some magical
experiences with
Google Now.
So I was invited to go to a
birthday party in Burlingame,
and Google Now reminded
me about the party.
And it even told me that
Burlingame was 30 minutes from
my house, which I didn't know.
And it was super helpful.
The more you use your products,
the easier it is to
make decisions and to have an
intuitive feel for what you
should be doing.
So I'll summarize my product
management advice.
One, paint a vision.
Two, when you don't know what
to do it, just make mini
milestones.
Roll that ball forward.
And three, use your products.
Since this is a Women's
Techmakers event, I thought
I'd close with my very
own lean-in story.
So back when all this Universal
Search stuff was
going on, I ended up
getting pregnant.
And when I was eight months
pregnant, my boss, Marissa
Mayer, suggested that I lead a
team of senior engineers to
come up with the Search strategy
for the next year.
Now, the Search strategy, the
normal process was to set this
meeting in mid-November.
But my baby was supposed to be
born at the end of October.
And so they were like,
hey, no problem.
We'll just move the date up,
which didn't give me very much
time to prepare.
And my baby was something that
you call transverse.
So he's lying on his side.
And I had to have a C-section.
So they moved the date up.
I moved my C-section to the very
last possible date, and
we met in the middle.
And on Wednesday, I gave the
strategy presentation.
On Thursday, I had my baby.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Now, this might
be horrifying to some of
you, but to me, it
was invigorating.
And it set me up to have a
leadership role in Search when
I returned from my leave.
And the point I want you to
takeaway is not that you need
to sacrifice your family
for your career.
I feel fortunate enough that
I haven't had to do that.
You see, there was no question
in my mind that given that
opportunity, I would want to
give that presentation.
And it was really huge that
my manager believed in me.
So the takeaway that I'd like
us to take is that as
managers, we shouldn't assume
people's abilities or desires.
We should ask.
As managers, it's our job to
enable greatness in our teams.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: So now
I'm so excited to
introduce Diane Greene.
Diane Greene is the
latest member of
Google's board of directors.
She's also a board member
for Intuit and MIT.
Diane is probably
most well-known
for founding VMware.
VMware went on to define the
visualization industry.
Diane was the CEO of VMware
from 1998 to 2008.
She took the company to $2
billion in revenue, and she
took the company public.
When I heard that I got to be
on the same panel as Diane
Greene, I was flabbergasted
and so excited.
Despite how intimidating her
resume sounds, Diane Greene is
actually quite approachable.
I heard her speak last year at
a Google event, and I went up
and introduced myself
afterwards.
And she was very friendly
and nice.
So if you get the opportunity
afterwards, I would encourage
you to shake her hand.
Diane is also a national
champion sailor.
With that, Diane.
[APPLAUSE]
DIANE GREENE: Thank you
for that introduction.
She went further than
I suggested she go.
So how did I manage to
do these things?
What I thought I would do is
take you on a whirlwind tour
of my life and try and highlight
where I thought I
learned valuable things.
And I grew up sailing,
racing sailboats.
And when you race a
boat, first, you
have to build a team.
And you have to get your team
all aligned on a single goal,
which is to win the race.
And then you need your strategy
to win the race.
You have to understand what the
wind is doing, understand
what the currents are doing,
and pay attention to your
competitors.
And if your competitors surprise
you or you get a wind
shift, you have to immediately
react and handle that and
continue winning the race.
And the last thing is the
engineering around sailing.
You have to prepare your boat.
It has to be ready to go fast,
and you have to tune it while
on the race course to
keep going fast.
And I think that's what
led me to train.
I trained as a mechanical
engineer and
then a Naval architect.
I came out to the Bay Area
to San Francisco
for my first job.
And the first thing I was given
to do was analyze some
mooring for an offshore oil
platform that was used for
firefighting.
And there was a big Fortran
program that looked like it
was the way to model this.
And so that's when I learned
how to program.
It was just this incredibly
powerful tool, software.
You could do anything with it.
I got pretty excited about it.
Was not very excited about
sitting inside behind a desk.
I really came to the Bay Area
for the wind surfing.
And so I quit that job, and I
moved to Hawaii, where I think
I had perhaps one of my favorite
periods of my life.
I lived sort of in a commune
where we were exploring
windsurfing.
It was sort of an early
microcosm of the tech industry.
We were just inventing
all kinds of things--
new sails, high aspect
sails, new shapes
of boards, new materials.
And all we did was build and
test this equipment every day.
It was really tremendous.
And from there, I went and ran
engineering for Windsurfing
International.
That was the company that had
the patent on the windsurfer,
which also taught me how abused
patents can be, because
they tried to control a very
rapidly expanding industry
with their patents.
I left that, and all
this time, I
continued to study software.
I went back up to the Bay Area
and enrolled in a graduate
program in computer science
at UC Berkeley.
Berkeley was a pretty happening
place at that point.
The grad students had a lab
full of brand new Sun
workstations that were based on
this Unix, a relatively new
open operating system.
Richard Stallman, who wrote
the GPL license,
was hanging out there.
I got to see the first graphical
user interface.
And it was just very exciting.
And I knew it's what I
wanted to keep doing.
I did still yearn
for adventure.
I've always really
loved adventure.
So I took a brief interlude and
went to use my computer
skills to be the computer expert
on a marine archaeology
expedition in Sipan, where we
excavated a Spanish galleon
and found gold.
And then I came back to the Bay
Area, and I went to work
at a succession of companies
in the tech industry.
The first one was Sybase, where
I really got hit over
the head with the value of
having engineers across
companies work together.
I made friends with an
engineer at Sun.
It turned out he was a
windsurfer, and we spent a few
months windsurfing and
writing software.
And we were able to get sort
of an order of magnitude
performance increase in the
Sybase system running on Sun.
And I really used that
when I built VMware.
All three companies were quite
an education in how important
it is to embrace change and
always go forward and invest
in the future.
Sybase didn't want to rework
their system to support
symmetric multiprocessing, and
that's sort of why Oracle
eclipsed them.
I went to work at Tandem that
had the world's best database
management system, but it ran
on proprietary hardware and
proprietary operating system.
And it was too hard to see the
business model for moving to
commodity open systems.
And they sort of sailed into
oblivion, getting bought by
Compaq and then by HP.
And then I went to work for
SGI, which was a pretty
aggressive tech company at that
point in time, and worked
on interactive television,
which was a
really exciting project.
But again, as the internet was
happening, and it was starting
at SGI, but instead, the founder
of SGI, Jim Clark,
left and founded Netscape.
And a number of us left
and started companies.
And that's when I finally
just decided
to stick with startups.
And so I did two successive
smaller startups.
They both had great visions.
I would say they maybe
executed too early--
nice financial outcomes.
The first one was streaming
video over the internet-- low
bandwidth, because there
wasn't much bandwidth.
And the second was internet ad
serving, interestingly enough.
At that point, I took a little
time off and decided to found
VMware, which was based on some
work my husband was doing
at Stanford around
virtualization.
And there's a few things I can
relate to what we did at
VMware to what I had
already learned.
For instance, Sun Microsystems
introduced these workstations.
People loved these workstations
and then brought
their servers into
the companies.
And at VMware, we used
the same strategy.
We had a workstation software.
People loved our workstation
software.
And then when we came out with
the server product, were
pretty quick to adopt it.
Our engineers worked with
the hardware vendors.
They worked with the
chip vendors.
storage vendors.
And then we worked with
all of those vendors
to take it to market.
And I'm just a huge believer in
collaboration in the industry.
And it was really effective for
VMware, but it was always
hard to convince other companies
to trust us and
partner with us.
But I think we always won
jointly together.
And then the last thing was
just how to adapt, how to
embrace change.
My job changed considerably
from zero to the sort of
6,000, 7,000 people the company
was when I left.
And it's just recognizing, OK,
this isn't working, and
constantly sectioning out parts
of my job that I just
didn't have time for
anymore and hiring
someone to do those things.
VMware was just a totally fun
adventure, building it with
all those people and seeing
the impact that it had.
And what I would say is, it's
not so important how.
There's just sort of
an infinite number
of ways to do things.
But when you see something that
you're very interested
in, that you think it can have
some real impact, the thing
that's important is to codify
that vision, see that vision,
enjoy the adventure of
building that vision.
And if you do enjoy it, it makes
it fairly easy to be
fearless about it.
So now we're going to shift,
and we're going to hear an
amazing talk by a hardware
lead at Google.
Jean Wang has a PhD In
electrical engineering.
In Photonics, she worked in the
optical communications and
then came to Google.
She's the hardware lead
on Google Glass.
As a board member, I
have Google Glass.
I love it.
It's so much more natural
than a phone.
And now you get to hear about
how she did this.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Thank you.
JEAN WANG: Hi, everybody
Smile.
So I'm very happy to be
here with you today.
I'd like to share with
you my Glass journey.
It's a three-part story that
spans across multiple domains.
And while it is yet unfinished,
I hope you share
my enthusiasm for what
is yet to come.
Before diving in, I'd actually
like to float this number
briefly and plant it
in your minds.
It has significance to
me and the story.
And in the meantime,
please [INAUDIBLE]
the number base that
I'm using.
So Glass, like many ideas,
started as a blank canvas.
As part of the initial team,
we came into the project
largely inexperienced
in the field of
head-mounted displays.
Instead, we had the ability to
divide and conquer through our
ability to learn and adapt.
While some of us focused on
optics, like myself, others
worked on cameras, sensor
systems, electronics.
And so we also came in with the
fundamental belief that
technology had ripened to the
point where we can make a
significant impact and create
something of significant use.
And that has led us into the
discovery phase and to find
out just what it was that could
be done to basically
minimize the barrier to
information access and to make
us connect with each
other in terms of
accessing our social sphere.
As part of the discovery
process, we looked at existing
products in the mobile space
and wanted to really
understand where it was that we
can make an impact in terms
of form factor.
For example, whether it was
bulky and had to fit into our
pocket or carry around
a bag for it.
Ease of access-- whether we
had to pull it out of our
pocket or a bag to actually
engage with it.
And also, ease of use-- whether
we were blocked when
we were using the device, or
whether we could look straight
ahead and talk with people
and not be distracted.
So to push on these pain points,
we did a number of
technical experiments.
Here's a helmet-mounted display
that did not allow us
to be hands-free
or wires-free.
And in the bottom, you can see
here is an early optical
experiment to help us understand
the technical
complexities in terms of how
optics sizes actually impact
the performance and
the image quality.
So with these considerations
in mind, we dived into
selecting components
that we can use and
make a viable solution.
So in the vast array of options,
we looked at what it
was we could just reuse
and customize.
Or was there something that we
had to invent for ourselves?
So we played around with a bunch
of pico projectors and
projectors.
We looked at optic components
such as lenses and prisms, as
well as interface devices--
touchpads, microphones,
speakers.
And underpinning the whole
system was electrical
components and board design.
So in this huge selection of
choices and huge array of
options, how do we
down select?
And so we filtered using
two key criteria.
One was power consumption, and
the second was weight.
So these two are basically
factors in enabling us to
first, wear a system all day,
and second, actually allow us
to want to wear a
system all day.
So we headed into the second
phase of prototyping.
Here are six example generations
of glass
prototypes.
Starting at the very top left,
we took the lowest hanging
fruit of simply putting mobile
phones to the side of the
head, and a pico projector
shining directly into the eye
to ride the image.
And so this was a bit bulky,
as you can imagine.
It came in at 167 grams.
And we wisely decided that we
could lighten the load by
taking the mechanicals
off the phone.
And that's our second proto
shown right up there in the
middle of top.
And so as you can see, over
time, we shifted from using
off-the-shelf components, such
as safety shields and frames,
into 3D painting
our own frame.
And that's shown here
in the third.
And you can also see that we
migrated into making our own
optical design architecture,
which is something we carry
thorough today.
And as you gradually evolve to
the very end, you see that
more and more, we use customized
components.
And we look at making our own
plastics and metals to get to
where we are today, which is
essentially the essence of
what Glass needs to be.
This provides the core and
provides a very minimalistic
system that allows us to run
around and be happy when we're
playing with the system.
And in addition to prototyping
with our hardware, Glass
derives its use from an
easy-to-follow UI.
And this is, by definition,
actually easy to make.
Along the way, we experimented
with a number of different
interaction concepts, for
example, head gestures.
That recent "SNL" skit was not
too far from our previous
truth, if you've seen it.
Also, we experimented with
porting the keyword
functionality to the touchpad.
But we found that it was a bit
too complex, even when running
the predictive word mode.
We also tuned the number of
lines of text, the font, the
size to basically optimize
for readability.
So through all of these
things, we found that
minimalizing and stripping down
to the very core allowed
for the best use case
and experience.
We also found that minor head
tilts and voice commands
allowed us for hand-free
experience, which is very
important when we're
busy dancing or
riding that roller coaster.
On the flip side, having the
touchpad and the camera button
allowed us for more quiet
modes of interaction.
So with the hardware and
software solutions converging
into a viable state, the team
actually turned to the
question of production.
It is possible to manually tweak
and baby one device to
get it to be close to ideal
in terms of cosmetics and
functionality.
However, we like to share
Glass more broadly.
And so that, to us,
quickly turns into
the question of scale.
How do we build not 1,000,
100,000, but upward towards a
Google of devices?
Layering in automation
is key to this.
And that means that not only
do we have to build Glass
itself, but we have
to build the
infrastructure that builds Glass--
the floor space, the
equipment, the
whole kit and caboodle.
And to add a bit more
complexity, we'd like to honor
individuality and human
preferences.
And that, to us, has meant
color options.
And that leads to color
complexity.
How do we make sure that on
the device itself, part to
part, the colors match?
And how do we make sure
that, between
devices, the colors match?
So production requires the
solutions to all these
questions and beyond.
Through these three phases of
discovery, prototyping, and
production, I have found that
Glass is both an innovation
and a reinvention.
By integrating highly compact
and new components, we've been
able to extend far beyond
[INAUDIBLE]
displays, beyond the last
several decades of
individualized movie players,
game consoles,
and aircraft systems.
On the other hand, I think that
Glass is a way in which
we can examine and develop new
fields that we can push beyond
and learn to be better connected
to each other, as
well as share a perspective
and have access to
information.
And all of this will allow us to
better emphasize as people
and synthesize.
So coming back to that number
at the very beginning, it's
been exactly, as of today, 1,111
days since I joined.
And this is a picture I
would not be able to
take without Glass.
I am paragliding over Coronet
Peak in New Zealand.
And just by looking at it, I can
recall what it was like to
soar with the birds
and to take in the
beauty of the landscape.
I've often been asked what the
"aha" moments have been the
project thus far.
And while I have a few,
I'm more excited about
what is yet to come.
There is a first here.
For example, barcode, QR code
scans, where we can get
[? just time ?] reviews of
movies, books that [INAUDIBLE]
were just about to take, but
we're not quite sure yet.
Then there's also never getting
lost and not bumping
into things while you're
looking at directions.
And then there's a whole
other level.
Recently one of my colleagues
exchanged his wedding vows
while wearing the device.
And I get goosebumps when I
imagine him reliving that when
he's old and gray and seeing
the reflection of a future
from his wife's eyes.
And then there's also a
physics instructor who
recently toured Cern
with the device.
And he did a Hangout back to
his classroom in Michigan.
And he was riding his bike down
the tunnel of a Large
Hadron Collider, showing his
classroom just how cool it was
while taking live questions
on the spot.
Then there's also another
example where Glass can mean
life or death.
It can help you translate to a
medical doctor in a foreign
country that you're allergic
to penicillin.
So through this process, I think
that there's just so
much potential in what
is yet to come.
That in pushing towards a new
perspective on information
sharing and perspective sharing,
we've come upon a new
environment in what Glass
can engender.
And when I have time to pause
and think about how far we've
come, I feel privileged to be
part of such a dynamic team.
Together we're striving forth
to bring forward this new
perspective.
And I count you, as developers,
as part of this
growing group.
There's just so much potential
and positive impact in keeping
in the moment, where information
is just at your
fingertips, and knowledge is
a twinkle in your eye.
And with that, I look forward
to your "aha" moments.
And we are back to discovery.
[APPLAUSE]
JEAN WANG: Thanks, everyone.
I'd like to hand it back to
Megan, one of my colleagues at
Google X, where she is
spearheading an idea for solve
for X to get us to
more moonshots.
[APPLAUSE]
MEGAN SMITH: Thank you.
Thank you, Jean.
And first off, thank
you to all of our
amazing lightning speakers.
You guys were incredible.
And also to Stephanie and Phoebe
and Mimi and Sinead and
Tara and Judith, who helped us
put all this together with the
amazing I/O team.
Just quickly, Larry talked
about thinking big.
We've been talking about
the idea of moonshots--
going 10x instead of 1x.
And so my colleague Astro and I
have launched this site and
this goal to have the meme of
moonshot thinking be something
that more of us do.
So solve for X is this
idea, there's a big
problem in the world.
There's some kind of crazy
technology that is there.
It feels like science fiction,
or there's a reuse of
something old that we just
might be able to use as a
radical solution to solve big
problems in the world, be they
self-driving cars or poverty
or water or just
more fun for everybody.
And the main thing about this
is that it's on the web.
It's open.
And so there's lots of proposals
already up, and
we've partnered with the X
PRIZE and TED and Arizona
State University, Singularity,
this great set of movies from
GE Focus Forward
about moonshots
that people are taking.
And so we're just trying to get
the conversation going and
really celebrate people who
are starting or who are in
process of moonshot.
Because we always celebrate
the people who made it.
But we really want
to get more about
collaborating and teamwork.
Bill Clinton calls the 21st
century the century of
creative collaboration.
And really, the web and all
the things we already know
about, we already feel that.
So that's what solve
for X is about.
And along those lines, there's
an idea that we
have as part of--
my clicker's not working--
about your X Like X is a
problem in the world or
something you're passionate
about.
So I was really lucky, as a
student, to get to take
acoustics at MIT from Professor
Bose, as in Bose Speakers.
He was an extraordinary
professor.
And at one point during our
classes, he paused, and he
went into a lecture
about life.
And one of the key things that
he said is, you guys are
really talented.
You're doing great things.
You're going for it.
The key thing now for you is
figure out what are you
passionate about?
In some ways, what's your X?
What do you care about?
What do you want to work on?
Because if you find that,
you're going to be
unstoppable, and you will do
extraordinary things to help
people and make things
great in the world.
And I think that the women who
we've heard from have found
their X. And I hope that
everybody will be
thinking in that way.
I welcome everybody to
stay afterwards.
I think Susan has to
catch a plane, but
everybody else is here.
There's a bunch of great
websites up, like the
makers.com site.
And in fact, today, somebody
just told me that Susan's
story is up on the
home page of AOL.
So she's one of the Makers,
and she's there.
And again, we've launched
Makers at Google.
And we hope that other
companies and other
organizations will start telling
the stories, which
leads me back to visibility.
And let's make people visible.
Help us do it.
And thank you so much
for being here.
[APPLAUSE]